all right welcome back to the third ever
episode of the iced coffee hour today we
have a guest here Christine you're the
first guest on the podcast
Wow you've never heard of it the name is
the iced coffee yeah a little bit too
late for iced coffee exactly so so grand
nose Christine this is my first night
ever actually meeting Christine but they
know each other for through their work
at the Oppenheim group together which is
really cool and I just have to say this
is one of the nicest houses I've ever
been in my entire life he's just saying
that it's really not that is incredible
yes this is this is your what do you
Paul it's on a basement because it's on
the ground level what do you the game
room okay yeah they have a skee-ball
table they have one of those duck hunt
things and they also I mean this is on
an air hockey tape yeah so that's yeah
this is only room in the house it's
actually completed as our game yeah I
would hang out here I mean this is
really where I would spend all of my
time
oh yeah as a movie theater like right
behind there's a full-on movie theater
room first off I think it'd be good if
we could just introduce you so people
kind of get an idea of who you are so
you got your start obviously it was a
you were an actress right basically what
happened with really tired of
pigeon-holed and these roles I didn't
want to do like I was you know getting a
hot girl number one girl number two I
was like was that how they credited you
are you serious was it actually I was
like all right I need something that's a
little more stable and I want to like be
my own boss and we're on ours
so that's kind of where real estate came
into play because you know I was friends
with Jason and then I saw him doing so
well and I loved that he was doing
something and it wasn't known boss so I
was like I want to be a part of that I
want to do that so that's kind of when I
gave up acting and started getting
involved in real estate full-time so
that's the transition well did you ever
go to college because you know Graham
was successful as a real estate agent
but he really didn't go to college did
you high I did not go to college I
couldn't afford it
I really wanted to go but my family
didn't have the fun so I actually didn't
go to college but in hindsight I'm glad
that I didn't waste my time because I
don't know him that because you know
what I want I want Jack to be able to
work with me full-time and he's like
babe it's cool grandma it's cool I have
a class until twelve and the comments do
it's stupid it's stupid I think we can
really really dream and do anything I
don't think college is that important
nowadays you know that's just my opinion
okay so it's so your best piece of
advice would you say that I should drop
out of college and do this thing with
Graham full-time actually you wouldn't
do it so you would do it anyway no she's
done it some unnecessary pressure yeah
you could tell him afterwards we're not
required to drop out of school did you
did you ever work any like normal jobs
because before I worked for Graham I I
was working as a busser at a restaurant
and I mean for me that was like that was
so miserable I remember every single day
on the job I was just thinking what can
I do so I don't have to do this anymore
and that's actually I tried so many
different like business ventures and
then finally through that I you know
I've been watching Graham's videos for a
while I just finally decided to send out
that email and try to contact him and I
tried it again and again yeah and then
that was why I actually I started
working for Graham was just because I
was doing a job that I just every single
second on that job as spent like
thinking what can I do so I don't have
to this morning did you work any 15
years old my mom had a lot of health
issues growing up so I needed to spend
more time with her so I went to an
accelerated school that was only four
hours a day so my hours I usually went
to school from like two to four two two
five two to six so then I could be with
her in the morning so my schedule was
really crazy and I started out working
at Sonic and I would work sometimes like
6:00 a.m. to noon
and then I would go to school after so I
worked at Sonic I worked at Taco Bell I
bartend Taco Bell I works at Costco I
had a bunch of really really and this
was a Texas right thanks Ashley yeah
totally nice so I've had drops all
across the board and that's kind of why
I see things differently and that's
really what has helped me kind of what
was your least favorite job
my least favorite job was Taco Bell
because they told me if I didn't take my
acrylic nails off they were gonna fire
me because it was a hazard for the food
yeah I could like break up so that was
my least favorite job because they made
me take off my acrylic nails and I was
about your nails you have these dangly
things I always show them to the yeah
get a nice close-up of those can I like
oh my god yeah she's got some danglies
on her name I love my nails I know a
function of it it's not function it
doesn't help you know it makes it
difficult to type you drag things I
practically I'm already scared enough
wearing a ring because I sometimes I
just jump up and touch things I just
like to I did it on a door once and my
ring got hot I almost pulled my yeah
because I read an article and like
Ripley's Believe It or Not when I was a
kid about a soccer players I mean I was
jumping over a chain-link fence
literally ripped his finger off because
he was wearing a ring so I mean I've
been scared ever since and it finally
happened to me and yeah speaking of
rings let's see that you got this beef
top didn't you this is not show it to
the game don't tell jack oh is it cool
Jack holds it okay wait let me let me
feel it first let me Jackson Debray I
just want I want some guys that way
that's a is I thought that was fake it
the whole time is that diamond so so
Jack hold it okay wait we gotta get your
reaction on this okay I know wait guys
oh you know what I can't have
get some b-roll get some zeroes so crazy
wait I think you saw when it was just
okay do you want to be in this as well I
I think I want I want both of your
reactions because you you don't I don't
I don't think you know either you know
what it just pulled it come on in come
on in come on in really quick hold that
just get right here but I want Jack to
hold it okay I want Jack to hold it when
Christine does the reveal because I
think Jack's reaction is gonna be the
best okay okay
was that the thing like on the Titanic
or something I don't know
it may as well have been so yeah so
guess how much you think that is oh wait
guess how much that would be so the
cufflinks that your husband wore during
the wedding
we're like 50,000 right 55 and they had
diamonds on them right yeah one and a
half you're gonna get 1 million yeah
well no no but I'm thinking this has to
be it's like this or Lamborghini all
right so like okay I think this could be
like a hundred and fifty $175,000 okay
but this ring is definitely over a
million dollars
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god definitely right but I don't
have to wear this every day okay yes but
I I never wear this like locked up in a
safety deposit box yeah I yeah yeah I
know
Wow look just want to Jack's reaction to
that that's all even pulling up to the
house whoa world even driving driving
through Beverly Hills
evn EVF that's Jack's not gonna be a
little yes yeah I feel like butterflies
nesting right now I feel you're not
wearing anything he's got the bug you
know these these rings right here okay
so so sorry okay
so Graham did he I'm sorry
give me let me give me a second cuz I'm
still like that that's shook me yeah so
Graham was guessing how much your
clothing and your jewelry would like
cost in the video for the second channel
and I want you to guess how much my
jewelry is okay okay so feel free to
hold these pieces of jewelry it guess
what they are
okay okay and hold them all right so
this is yellow gold and this is heavy so
platinum okay let me let me guess let me
guess - I mean let me see I don't know I
just want to feel it I'm gonna let you
do your thing all right I have a
different answer wrong wait well I
didn't really shine you know and okay
yeah yeah alright well I see I see no
line in the middle now that I'm looking
closer which is made from like an
improper cast so I would actually know
this still is yellow gold this one is
not platinum actually this is like
something this is sterling silver so you
ready for big reveal good
so I actually made both of these and
this one's 14 karat gold
and this one is silver bullion bar so
it's like cool yeah I was gonna say
summer silver and I was like you can
call it improper cast if you want we
also did that thing where it so you gram
was guessing the price of all of your
clothes I want you to guess the price of
what Graham and I are weighing right now
okay yeah you got to pick to start off
with our shirts yeah I would say this is
something like this looks like Old Navy
or Zara to me it's probably $15.99 okay
and then I think you're wearing corduroy
pants probably from somewhere I like
these look a little like more expensive
money I think this is probably like a
hundred all our PR jeans I would say
okay okay and then Graham I think that's
probably something like Zara as well and
then the jeans let's see the jeans
they're probably go ahead and read a
little more expensive yeah so this it's
Brett's so in the jeans or brett-brett
opening that changes thing so
technically they were free for me
knowing that their breaths I would for
sure
and like a three dollar pair of jeans I
think five hundred these are product
The Prodigy pne's that Brett gave me for
free yeah and this I don't know I don't
know makes a shirt for prize yeah thanks
Brett see your passes are actually there
I mean for the shirts about $60 shirt
okay all right on your shirt
these pants are probably four hours
they're probably $80 or so all right
I know women's clothes men's clothes is
like so hard for me though that's that's
a degree where my nicest clothing for
the podcast he did he got dressed up
today for this yeah I kid you not this
is the nicest she's dressed in a very
long
yeah have you ever been recognized like
just from selling sunset definitely I
mean I was at the gas station yesterday
people were like you pump your own gas
with the nails yeah that's gone that's
really cool because I am I've always
told Graham like I was like man it's
crazy that that Graham gets recognized
yeah he does and I've never been with
him one even though it's been recognized
until last week it finally happened I
brought it to Graham several times like
I can't wait for the time because we
never go out we're always at home so
that's really what it is yes so exciting
for me and and yeah we were in the car I
was driving and we were just going into
an intersection it was late at night
coming back from a burger place we come
to a red light at an intersection I come
to a stop and then I go and as I'm going
like it was a very very quickly very
quick as I'm going someone that was
standing on the corner there's a Graham
which is crazy to me like I'm still
blown away at that because Graham was
still he's like sunk down in his seat
yeah whatever in the car I do full
slouch modes like you won't even see me
like this is no gradually like this in
the car like looking down at his phone
and somehow this like this this lady
still recognized you know I believe it
because actually I get a lot of my
followers they're like oh my god you
work with that's cool
I get a lot of people to is you should
you collab with Christine so we're
finally doing it finally doing it yeah
exactly
also do you from working as a real
estate agent do you have any crazy
stories about open houses do you have
any stories that really come to you yes
I do
meri and I were doing an open house
together and we locked and closed
everything up and then the second we
left there was people that broken
house and still all of the alcohol in
the house and that's all they stole was
alcohol there was other valuables but
they just stole all the booze in the
house so very strange but that's my only
crazy open house sorry gran that's um
yeah I got a few of them one well this
was actually at this same house believe
it or not so I'll try to keep this PG
one this is one of my like within the
first year some guy came in and it was a
busy open house and got naked and got in
the pool and refused to leave and so I
was with my mentor at the time and he
was the one who called the police and
then I don't know I told him to leave so
that was one of them the other one was
it was actually my first ever open house
and I showed up not knowing like we had
no instructions are really what to do
but just like here is the house here the
set of sheets like the owners gonna be
home just yet so I get there a little
bit earlier thirty minutes early and the
house is a mess and the guy had a
massive party the night before and I got
in and I was just like brand-new not
knowing what I was doing and there are
people sleeping on the couch it was like
12:30 I think people sleeping on the
couch the owner was still in bed there
were beer cans everywhere the whole
thing was a mess I mean they had a
massive party than I thought and I
didn't know what I was doing so that was
you being realistic this is one of my
first open houses change wow that's
that's crazy I'm sure there's others
that are just not thinking about I know
how much in alcohol do you think they
stole was it like hundreds of dollars
yeah my other story is just a little
stupid thing but I had to sell her who
was at the open house and there was this
celebrity that came and I had no idea
who it was
it's Sophia Loren do you know who that
is
yeah I don't know
you don't know yes if you like I don't
know so anyway she walks in the open
house I ask her to sign it what she
brunette right yeah I can't right I
think so she's a older lady no yeah but
anyway so so she walks in the open house
and like hey do you mind signing it and
the owner was furious you don't ask her
to sign in we know who she is you do not
have got and got really upset at me and
and I was she's got a sign-in and like
because I was told what to do like get
everyone to sign in or she doesn't need
to sign it
but anyway ended up calling it my boss
that I was asking a celebrity to sign in
and they should like I shouldn't be
asking something like that I don't know
I feel like they would want to be so
furious but some some actress I have um
I have one crazy work story this is not
from my work with Graham but this is
from my work at a restaurant so I was
yeah so I I was a bus alright so I would
get the plates now to clear off the food
and give it to the dishwasher sometimes
there's perfectly good food that people
don't eat all the way and I must admit
you see fish and chips
they eat two of them they leave one it
looks untouched I have done that Oh like
you don't know if someone like was like
put it in their mouth and then they
didn't want it yo you lose it that's not
closer to grace but that's like I did
that every shift right like I would eat
that like no problem one time there was
a chicken saute and it was like skewers
with little pieces of chicken on it and
it had like you know it's a glazed over
cuz they like cook it or what I don't
know how they do it and it was set
perfectly on the bus tray and I'm like
okay chicken satay yeah sure I'll eat
some so I grab it and I take a bite and
then a guy walks back and there's like
one empty skewer and the guy sees so
it's an expediter the person who took
out the food he sees it and he was like
oh my god who ate the chicken satay who
ate the chicken satay and I was like oh
my he's gonna serve this still he hadn't
said yeah so I was like I'm in really
really deep trouble
and then he goes oh no and I was like
what happened what happened that you can
saute and he was like oh so I was taking
it out to it to a table and outer deck
and someone in the parking structure
that's above the restaurant
it's like hocked a loogie
oh my god off the parking structure Wow
landed right on the chest boy really
good I cleaned these chicken saw pages
like I like a like two sewers and
apparently just a random person's loogie
hocked off the parking structure
perfectly honor the skin taut days and
he said like to the customer he's like
did you see that the customers like yeah
and he just brought it back and and I
was like oh that's so terrible that's
that sucks that someone ate these
chicken satay is like I feel sorry for
that person I hope you really learned
your lesson and no one knows no no I
think I feel sick to my stomach for like
three hours I don't know how yeah well I
beaten food off other people's plates
before not eating there you know yeah
right yeah so I used to be a fun game
actually this is I that you you don't
know in high school
my friends would dare me to go up to
like random tables and say would you are
you gonna finish that I do that now but
but yeah and every now and then people
would give me food if I walk up like are
you gonna finish that
can you shower scene exactly right no I
have a friend he had a really bad habit
we'd go into restaurants he was really
for more frugal than you he wouldn't eat
out because he was too scared to spend
any money on there used to be me oh yeah
that was a funny one it was a
millionaire woman she would turn off the
water yeah yeah I save on civic gas but
but he would go into these restaurants
with us we'd all order food and he would
ask the the person working at the
register he would ask them for garbage
food quote-unquote do you guys have any
like garbage food food that your guys
are gonna like throw away you know just
like give it to me or whatever
he got it probably like 40 to 50 percent
of the time any shot she would ask he
call it garbage food food that he is
willing to put into his system he would
literally refer as garbage food give me
yes yeah this is a good second channel
stuff right there okay I like that so so
where did you meet Gramps or when did
you meet him no where'd you meet grant
and what was your first impression of
him um so obviously I think probably the
first time we met was at the office I
think and my first impression was I
think we went to the police across the
street all of us together as a group
which I want to say it was like BB it
was before it was BC or La Petite maybe
yeah yeah so I just remember that you
took everyone's scraps oh he's like can
I get a box can I get a box and I was
like I was like actually I kind of loved
that because otherwise looking you waste
it and I was like damn I have mad
respect for this guy like I love that
but it's you know it's it's so ballsy
and that about you cuz I'm ballsy as
hell you know his people would always
ask me how do you get your food budgets
so low and it was from doing stuff like
that but I get it because I so much
weight good
so you never lost the thing you did in
school you'd still ask people for their
scraps
yes great I would take everything like
bread I would be at the office at 9:00
p.m.
of course like you have like a llama
it's worth good food yeah I got to eat
for dinner more than 40 pop music yeah
for all the different little bits and
yeah Jason he's terrible it's a whole
bunch of stuff and just weightless
mm-hmm the rest of it yeah
and so I would sit like like the you
know vulture I don't blame you just like
patiently waiting they prefer to delete
I don't blame you io Jason so much for
that that's awesome so you thought he
was awesome like you thought because I
thought was so ballsy I was like I love
this guy's vibe I dig it that's cool
yeah
so what were your thoughts when gran was
what was your thoughts on Graham like
changing from spending a lot of time you
know being a real estate agent to now
pursuing you know spending much more of
his time being a youtuber what did you
think about uh I think it's great and I
love what you do I love that you know
you you you own a duplex you live in the
bottom you brought out the top you're
basically living for free I love that
you were talking about your portfolio
and various things that you're doing in
stock market I think that's great I
think that people really value you in
your opinion so I love that you're
spending more time on YouTube and
getting this stuff out to people and
then as you're doing that you know you
can probably think of ideas along the
way and stuff you want to do and you
know so I think it's really inspiring I
think it's good and I'm happy of me the
transition thanks you gotta remind
everyone to smash the like don't forget
to smash the like button area do you
ever watch his videos and obviously
you're you're now aware you are aware
was frugal mentality what do you think
about his frugality like do you fully
ship it do you think sometimes it's like
a little overboard what do you think
about it you know um yes I probably seen
all your videos big fan actually and I
am a big supporter of anyone doing
something to an extreme so I don't think
he's crazy at all
like I think it's really cool what he's
doing because you know I'm a big fan of
people that are extremists and you're an
extremist in a great way
so a huge supporter of major props to
you you're a bit of an extremist in the
opposite absolutely very opposite that's
why I can't wait for that vlog
day-in-the-life and we're gonna switch
would be I would love to do that but do
you want my actual day in the life like
like a real not exciting well I mean no
well obviously like right you know amp
it up you know because I just watch TV
all day so you don't end weekends with
gravity
yeah yeah I mean it's pretty tame it's
it's pretty fancy yeah yeah well don't
you guys want to see that all right
we'll be going to it well let me not
tell you about it we'll keep it for us
yeah yeah but one question I've noticed
a lot of the people that work at the
Oppenheim group they're really really
good-looking people mm-hmm thank you so
except for one of course do you need to
be really attractive to be a real estate
agent because everyone is absolutely
beautiful
mm-hmm like how important is it to be
attractive it's it's not important
honestly if anything it's really
detrimental because it's it's really
really hard for me for people to take me
seriously because they look at me you
know and sometimes they won't give me
the time of the day because they're like
there's no way she's smart there's no
way she knows anything so if anything
it's actually it works the opposite for
me but um it just so happens that
everyone is very good-looking does it
make the job easier
not really does it make it harder to
that clients absolutely I think it does
yeah yeah I think you could get your
foot in the door for way more prospects
but because you have so many more
prospects it's weeding through all of
them it becomes a really different yeah
I agree I would definitely agree with
that because yeah I mean I've seen some
of the guys to come and look you know
I'm not good guys come in the door many
times I just walk in there we take
head-on you wear to work there are
things to wanaka where with the guise of
buying a house yeah what is this place
why did this place to get our attention
and then they walk over to one of the
girls hide the desks it's like you know
I'm looking to buy a four to six million
dollar they always say pocket listing
yeah populous pocket listing it means
something doesn't exist because it's
true shipping is awesome an off-market
market which means nothing on the market
satisfies this it's gotta be off the
market you know four to six what area
doesn't matter
by the way pocket listing is just key
word for unrealistic buyer yes it really
is it really is
but anyway what they do is if you could
send me some listings you know what's
what's your number and then and they
decide and then you know what's your now
it's all a so it's a classic
yeah maybe we should meet up and discuss
oh yes this over lunch yeah do you get a
lot of people that like try to go inside
of the Oppenheim group now Stan's since
it has like a Netflix show you happy to
get lots on the door so how do you get
oh yeah it's really daily stuff walks it
may be anyone used to be able to just
open up which is exactly new clients
like do people like walk by like tell me
and they look all the time like it's
that's really and definitely on
experience right I mean it's a real
working office but I always used to stay
late and work late and then I couldn't I
couldn't work at my desk anymore because
what would happen is so many people
would come by and then put your face up
against the the glass and then also I'd
be working there and they were just
people looking at it could get so I had
to move upstairs and hide behind like
like one of the tables upstairs what the
people wouldn't see wow yeah yeah that's
that's cool that's really really
interesting so do clients even go inside
yeah so they still go inside you just
have to get the door open for you from
right there's a buzzer and you watch the
door do you think that like at a certain
point you guys would just like move off
was such a busy street I mean I think
Jason loves you no I think he loves the
Sunset Strip and loves that location
yeah it's it's really one of the best
locations it's a cool location yeah I
can't see him ever moving from that
location okay if anything I think he
would open up another office and maybe
go in between right on the point but
that's about it
hmm okay let's talk about the different
styles of real estate agents because I
know grandma has a really laid-back
style and he never really pushes like
his his clients to like buy the house or
anything he's really relaxed and that's
why they trust him a lot what's
different between your style and his
style if you don't have that style my
style is actually very similar to you
I'm very casual with my clients as well
I'm not pushy I do
you know if they're not calling me I'm
not like you know ring ring ring and I
know a lot of agents that are really
obnoxious and turned off when people act
that way so I try to do my best to be
like a really casual cool laid-back
friend more than anything but still
listen to them and value their opinion
without being over pushy because there's
nothing worse than like salesman you
know the sales and sales is salesy so I
try to be really like cool yeah one
question I've always had for people that
like are very wealthy is I can't ask
this for Graham but um do you like when
you're out do you ever like think like
your drive this probably see the
question what you're driving and you're
like oh I want to get some food and
you're like six minutes away from you
home you're like well I can save you
know $8 or $10 if I just go home like
does buying food ever concern because
like I'm just wanted for wealthy people
like what's $10 like know why even when
I was really poor I I would always like
I would always splurge so if I wanted
like a nice meal I would just like put
it on my credit card so I've always
actually been that way because I've
always loved like nice food so um the
answered the question would be like no
but even when I was like really poor I
was still like oh I'll just put it on my
credit cards whatever if I wanted it
I'll eat it you know okay do you sweat
like going out to lunch sometimes like
you think like oh I used to for me it
used to be a lot worse now it's stuff
like eased up drop in like $15 you know
no I could drop cases without worrying
about it but yeah like two or three
years ago $15 I'd just rather save it
always because I went to I went to a
ramen we know ramen I went to a Thai
place and I got fur and it was a $25 I
was okay that's crazy
I here's the thing right I go in I'm
gonna get the combination fuh and it's
gonna cost $16 then the person I'm going
with he's all yo we should get some
spring rolls and I was like mmm you know
like the combination is already enough
but I'm not gonna say no and he's like
we should split it in like okay spoon
was like $9 so brought me up from like
you know a $16 meal plus you know tip
and tax to now like $25 meal I was
sweating it a little bit but I have to
learn you know just drop it after it's
already done but you know those are
so those habits and will never change
because that I still think about that as
well like I get a salad sometimes and
it's $22 I actually had a conversation
the other day with Davina and I called
her and I was like do you know how much
this orange juice is the air one I was
like so Sarah one is $15 I got to do a
real party everyone this is wild so I
still react the same way that you do to
certain things because I know it's not
normal to pay $15 for orange juice
that's insane everyone we $15 you Ornish
- yeah Erewhon is like the Rodeo Drive
what's her day or Drive exactly what is
it no you're kidding me is he actually
kidding I think no he's not kidding I've
never heard of it
okay Oh Drive Beverly Hills Rodeo Drive
oh wait where does he live we've been
terrible now now he's it's a street
that's a street friggin I've never heard
of her a daily drive it's like rub this
it's like never having like what's Paris
like I know okay okay if you if you want
a comment that you don't know what Rodeo
Drive is to make me feel better please
do so I I didn't I don't know it's a
street how I find no route 66 it's
probably that's good enough baby yeah I
would agree in the world next is 66% I
don't drive there maybe like I'm people
known for a day I Drive it's like it's
like the biggest shopping district Mecca
it has a shot I thought it's residential
know how you said I just thought it'd be
mansions but it's a shopping center but
you drive further down and Rodeo Drive
is a big shopping site house like every
high-end luxury brand you could think of
is on Rodeo Drive like they they have to
be able to drive the statement I guess
those are their stories
oh I think they won't have a presence on
that Street what do we got a drive see
there sometimes anything yeah we were
driving through Beverly Hills - I've
only done that like maybe once or twice
it was crazy for me like I was just like
every house that we saw like my jaws
dropped like one inch low next reaction
kind of messy yeah really really I'm
still shucking up from your like III
still like I'm just I can't stop
thinking I get hopping about EDM water
how did you say that's an even easier I
thought you were Gillian water I don't
know I've never drank before I drink
Arrowhead and Nestle yeah you the Sun
yeah I don't even drink Tucson II isn't
that a nice one anyways alright IV on
water okay yeah
alright we got to go to Rodeo Drive
sometime cuz I would love to see I'd
love to see okay so what's what's like
the average cost of your lunch because
every day for lunch even lunch and
dinner sometimes I'll do like peanut
butter and jelly sandwich for lunch and
dinner yeah if I get really desperate
yeah sometimes I'll just need like two
or three days like I obviously I still
do not like spending a lot of money on
food it's so like freaks me out like at
$22 salad is just not right like it's
not okay
I would say the average cost though
would be like anywhere probably fifteen
dollars I would say anything over
fifteen dollars on one single item I'm
just like that's not normal you know but
I do cook a lot at home so I've let it
go Suri's that's fair yeah
Graham you do the healthy choices not as
much not as much I've got a girlfriend
now that cooks ah alright like I had
leftovers today that's smart
yeah that's smart I gotta get nervous
and in oatmeal at least so i i've gone
from the which macabre what do they
called the cliff bars quaker quick bars
ninety-nine cents a Clif Bar that's good
Asli but but you think now oatmeal is I
found more filling just as good just
oatmeal and honey what kind of oatmeal
Quaker huh Quaker yeah quicker talk not
bad yeah a thing and you get a whole
thing for like three bucks a minute
that's best smart there's another water
no mmm-hmm I used to use water I doesn't
I only use I've never heard of milk
Romeo I've never heard of an oatmeal I
didn't know it was a so much better well
thank you sherry Matt was drinking with
like half the thing is like really good
yeah yeah that's always joke guys
totally no rodeo drivers and even Evian
water I know what it always I'm just
joking
all right let's see here what's the
biggest waste of money like that you've
ever done like what's something you
spent money on you're just like ah I
shouldn't have I shouldn't have done
that advice or hiring people really yeah
I'm high race what sort of advice well
you know I was talking to a marketing
company about a new business venture
that I'm doing and you know they map out
you know the inspiration and do mood
boards and all this crap and you know
sort of the words their budget for
helping me build out my brand and vision
was $100,000 this does not include who
did you who is that this is a big
marketing have a good look at legit a
Dallas yes serious no no no I I
recognized it was a complete and total
waste of money and just outrageous but
you didn't actually spend it
no of course not as soon as they told me
that I was like you've got to be what
have you spent money I mean that's
absurd but what have you spent money on
that year you have regretted it then I
prefer a sorry than ever good um I would
just say hiring crappy people hmm
Graham anything funny in that Chapel a
burrito a couple weeks ago geez I would
say oh this is a feel like I heard a
really bad landscaper years ago and I
had to oh yeah hold on can you think oh
you know what a contractor that was my
second mantra yeah
money in a contractor and maybe some
furniture paid parking to paper don't
get grant started on paid parking I like
that one that one day like five dollar
parking yeah or any time that I go
gambling which I love so mad at my side
I've not regretted any amount of
gambling no good for you only game with
a pewter box I lose it it's okay I'm
upset if I lose like $100 a night yeah
that sucks yeah yeah I lost no I would
turn when I turned 21 I went gambling
with my dad Las Vegas I spent I lost
like $500 gambling it was bad like I
caught myself at 300 I was like I was
like I'm not gonna lose more than 300 I
lost your engine I was like why stove
one day there was only the first days
it'll like have a limit at 500 bucks and
they lose it and they're like I'm gonna
go get another 500 bucks that's what
here's the thing but I see them win it
all back and way more and I'm like oh
man if they're doing it really then if I
do it I just lose more no I know it was
my 21st worth of though so I feel like
it's pretty excusable I mean I lost
pocket I had pocket aces and I lost on
against pocket nines have you know like
poker they play poker okay that's all I
wanted to play oh I think you just
played blackjack no I think Black Jacks
to luck oriented I think about maybe I
should play more blackjack see how much
money in focus the obvious you don't
have talents yeah exactly
Lucky's probably your best bet
where do you think in life you are
frugal like where where do you really
tried not to spend so much money um when
we are with vendors a lot of vendors
when we're doing things and hiring
people I'm like well I know that
that's really not how much it cost you
know what when I'm doing things like
breaking down the cost ratio to how much
I actually know something is that's
where it gets like annoying for me
for example stuff like diamonds you know
like I'm just giving you one example of
I mean like cardiac I would never in a
million years buy anything from well I
have a Cartier bracelet but other than
that my it's stuff where I you know know
what the value is and see what people
are charging for it and that really
pisses me off so like for example a my
wedding we had a vendor that was
charging three times the markup on the
snow that we had falling because they
knew it was winter and everyone wanted
the snow so you know I was like this is
not okay like I'm really good actually
at like cutting corners and saving so
that was one thing that pissed me off
when people overcharged because they
know that they can and so I would say
stuff like that how much does it cost
for fake snow fake snows a lot I think
it was like probably some around 50
grand for the night did go by pillows at
Sears cut them open
get some industrial fans really what's
it made out of like like I'm in dunno
it's all see so it's really like a like
it's so it's kind of wet a little bit so
some dove bars they just blend up and it
really is so because people were getting
it like in their hair and their yeah oh
no it's Elvis but like the you know
through was a she and she is in the
whole night yeah they have a crew there
like mama granite bakes know if some
dude is in the back pressing a button I
would just if I was at that wedding and
I knew that's no cost of fifty thousand
dollars I would just be grabbing as much
as I can I'm just stuffing it away it's
just soap its soapy water is really what
it is like I can imagine going and like
you get a whole bunch of like you know
you take a bubble bath you get the best
really well challenge blowing that
everywhere that's really all it is yeah
I'm like why am i spending money on that
yeah geez
so we just have a few just gag questions
that we like to ask on the show would
you rather fight one horse-sized duck or
a hundred duck-sized horses on your
deathbed horses
everyone says that
I mean horses are probably more
dangerous than Ducks given like if they
are the same size they are probably like
a really dangerous peak and if it was a
huge size it would be really lethal yeah
the lethal beak yeah okay well how many
do you think you could take then all at
once
the horses yeah like they're surrounding
you I mean like ten max no more than
that no you can take more than that so
you're done neither way yeah where the
duck sized horse you've done you put 100
100 horses okay so like horses that are
this tall oh how many of those can you
take oh yeah I mean a lot like 500 huh I
didn't even say I'll I think I said I
could take 300 you do realize this whole
room they're small right you're like
yeah hi yeah you can't kick them not
until they're nipping at your calves and
stuff you fine I think 500 is a good
number and you won't have a hundred
duck-sized horses send them this way let
us know we'll put them in a hip put them
in a cage with cage fight yeah let's see
here second question is Mayo and into I
know I'm right now
is mayonnaise an instrument is
mayonnaise an instrument you have to
think about all cultures I don't get
that I mean I know what I know what is
man like mayonnaise is it an instrument
like yes all right
she doesn't think so he's a dangerous
answer yeah it was fun the spongebob
episode yeah but then some guy on
YouTube made mayonnaise an instrument
and proved I haven't seen that yeah the
final question for today's podcast does
pineapple have a place on pizza
absolutely Graham yeah you know yes yeah
thank you
yeah yeah of course of course ranch yeah
ranch is delicious pineapple is just No
oh yes you should be what's ranch do you
wanted you have anything here come in
come in do you have anything to say is
it on the mayonnaise or
pineapple or what order anything
anything you'd like to comment on the
spinal have pineapple have a place on
pizza oh yeah yeah yeah have you heard
of Rodeo Drive yes but no I didn't know
a few years ago no I don't see hey guys
Jack and I grew up very close yeah I
always feel like your dad drives it's in
all the movies it's like a yeah I don't
watch movies that's probably why I'm
literally a hurry-up not watching
anything okay that's probably it
that's the problem I don't know that
we'll give the money at videos thinking
you're a dare drive and just seeing it
I'm just being baffled just yeah the
price tag oh my gosh I think I would
probably fall apart
man I wanna I'm walking into Gucci
stores and then just like guess what how
much is this that's so stupid you know
why would you
yeah I thought to the the canvas shoes
were cheaper like the Gucci candidacy I
thought they were like 400 bucks there's
no like seven $800 for pair of shoes no
yeah that's crazy
there's bring your way though we move
trying to go to Gucci no like oh this is
out of your price range you're not gonna
know they know to end it off
one thing I forgot to say it's gonna
stop recording in a second
should we can click it oh no we're good
we're good it's a six-minute clip so
we're gonna okay yeah quickly yeah
favorite Taco Bell Adam go Sheila but
beef julep is spring go oh favorite talk
about what item Oh crickey tacos it's a
classic I like the loaded
grillers order well of course he doesn't
like $1 each
not so real yeah yeah it's neither $0.99
or something yeah nothing's talked about
that I like the not the supreme gordita
so Gordon eateth supreme they just have
a like a $2.00 meal with a drink and a
chips good deal all righty
so I you go ahead and you know sign us
off shout out well I hope you guys had
fun I'm so honored that I was on what is
it your first the third third yes I am
the first gasps on the third of the
podcast yeah thanks for hanging out with
us and click the smash that like button
like like this match button yeah
subscribe make sure to add only
television if you want to follow us
anywhere I'll link to all of that and
also where you can get your two free
stocks from we've all linked down below
in the description to free stocks value
1000 for 1499 that's false advertising
those 1,400 so with everyone yeah thanks
for watching it until next time I'll
wave we should all right this is fun I
love it